if anything besides being practical and  start making money instead of losing  money is what you remember from this  talk this morning please make it that  you need to go to a senior citizen home  and volunteer for one day here's what I  want you to do spend one day at a senior  citizen home and I promise you you will  leave with the following you will leave  that the scariest thing in the world the  scariest thing in the world to human  beings is regret what you will see in  those 80 and 90 year olds some will be  happy and they'll be content but you  will see something at scale that scares  the living [ __ ] out of me  it's called regret the amount of people  that wish they did things is scary and  let me promise you something when you're  93 it's hard to pull it off  [Music]